[gun fires]
[tires squeal]
I'm not going to say
it doesn't ever happen,
but not very often.
And we don't drive a lot of Ferraris.
My name's Andy Kay.
I'm a private investigator,
and I'm also the owner of Kay
and Associates Investigations
here in Los Angeles for
about the last 30 years.
Today I'm going to be looking
at private-investigator scenes
from movies and television.
What do you want?
HDS, sir. And how are you this afternoon?
All righty, then.
I've been a delivery
guy a couple of times.
I've been a waiter.
I've actually asked a maître d' to give me
the bottle of wine to deliver
to the table one time.
So, yeah, it happens.
There's actually laws against
impersonating another person.
Walking up with the outfit,
nobody's going to say anything about it.
If you go up there and say,
"Hey, I am FedEx,"
then you're stepping over a line.
Son of a b----!
Ace: That was a close
one, ladies and gentlemen.
When little animals go missing,
unless we have good information
that somebody has stolen
it or it's a big dog,
expectations are pretty low.
It happens, and we've gotten some back.
Nobody's going to do it like that,
because you would not know, first off,
that the dog was going
to be anywhere accessible
in the first place,
that the guy is going
to even answer the door
in the second place.
There is just so much
presumption in this case
that it would just never happen that way.
Except for Jim Carrey.
[engine sputters]
No problem! It gets flooded.
We'll just wait a few seconds.
[man yells]
[glass shatters]
All that planning just to be caught
at the end with a baseball bat. [laughs]
Usually we don't have
to worry about getaway.
The big thing about being
a private investigator
is to be private,
so that they don't ever
know we were there.
I would give this clip a 2.
It's designed to be comedic,
and it's very good at it.
Sherlock: Ah, sergeant, we haven't met.
Dimmock: Yeah, I know who you are.
And I'd prefer it if you didn't
tamper with any of the evidence.
The police officer,
first thing he said was,
"I prefer you not be
disturbing our evidence,"
and that's exactly correct.
They would have never
let him in those doors
at that point. Once they were there,
they would have taken over the scene.
The disdain for what he was saying
shows you that they are not big fans
of private investigators,
which is a lot of the times
the situation with police officers.
A lot of times we are
working with the police,
a lot of times we are
working against the police.
Left-handed?
I'm amazed you didn't notice.
All you have to do is
look around this flat.
Coffee table on the left-hand side.
Coffee mug handle pointing to the left.
Power sockets, habitually he
used the ones on the left.
You can notice things
that are out of sync.
I mean, that's extreme, for sure.
And all that's going to come
out in pathology anyway.
They're going to know if
he's right- or left-handed.
There should be dozens and dozens
of photos of the crime scene.
So they're going to notice
some of those things.
There's nothing there
that wouldn't come out
through the normal process anyway.
And the private investigator's
not going to be a part of that.
There's a lot of different things
you can tell about people
from looking at them
and appearance-wise,
but if you start assuming too much,
you might've fallen into a trap
for what they're, you know,
trying to make themself be portrayed as.
So, you look. You don't
draw conclusions that way.
I would rate that at probably a 5,
just because it's entertaining
and you have to make it such,
otherwise it's not going to work.
[phone dials]
[phone rings]
Hi, this is Gia.
Well, there's a whole
lot of violations of law
in this one.
We have this thing called
expectation of privacy
that we're supposed to work within.
And so if you can see
something from public view,
without magnifying it, you can record it.
If you can hear a conversation in public,
again, the expectation of privacy is gone.
So you can do that.
Taping phone calls,
it's a two-party state.
It's in California, obviously.
They said they're in West Hollywood.
So you cannot record that phone call.
If she was licensed, she
wouldn't be for much longer
if she was caught doing it.
You can get the information other ways.
And you definitely couldn't use it
in any kind of a court or a prosecution,
because they're going to toss it all out.
So it's worthless for anything other than
developing corroboration with
other evidence that you find.
Gia: Hey, something's happening.
You need to get over here right away.
I've had situations like this
where we actually just
rented the apartment
across the street.
That way, if I can open my
window and see into theirs,
it's fair game.
So there's ways around what she's doing.
And this is, obviously,
an area where she wouldn't expect anybody
to be looking in on her.
Although if people have
public access to that roof,
she could also be in the same situation.
Say it's a rooftop bar
and she's just sitting there at a table.
She has the right if she can see it.
I have to get a closer look.
Yes, sometimes cameras do come in handy.
Now there's much smaller magnifications
that we use that do the same job.
We also use drones a
lot with magnification,
because if we can see it from there,
we can get anywhere on it.
If it's in public space,
we can magnify on it.
I'll give this clip two stars,
just because it's absolutely nothing
a private investigator is going to do.
Did you converse with Harlan at that time?
Well, he was there, we must have spoke.
In his study?
I don't think so.
From an interrogation standpoint,
it was actually pretty good.
He left information out of the question
so that they could try
to extrapolate on it,
and that way you can see
which way they're going.
You could see that Don Johnson
was coached a little bit on how to react
while you're trying to hide something
and you're trying to
convey something else.
So it was done well.
Just the way he led his expressions
and then, "Oh, yeah,"
you know, kind of
things. Things like that.
The things that you look for are
when they look away a lot,
when they have to stumble,
when they say things that
are just out of line anyway.
They try to divert from something
when you ask a question.
Now, a lot of people will hang their hat
off of watching some ex-FBI agent
tell you how to read people.
And once you do that, you
start missing everything else.
You really have to trust yourself
and your interactions with people.
So you really have to pay
attention to those body cues
and facial cues without becoming a victim
of counting on every single
one to mean a certain thing.
Who hired you?
I do not know.
An envelope of cash showed
up at my apartment yesterday
with a news clipping of Thrombey's death.
Well, actually just today we got a case
where we have an anonymous client.
I know she's a female.
That's all I really know about her.
So it's very strange,
but, yeah, it happens.
You really want to know
who your clients are
the majority of the time.
I give it ...
7.
One of the more realistic
portrayals so far.
What makes you certain
that your husband is
involved with someone?
A wife can tell.
Good scene.
Now, as I recall, in this movie,
that was not the actual person
she was portraying herself to be.
But she was right about that statement.
When she said, "A woman knows
these things," she was right.
Women know.
We actually keep the numbers every year,
'cause we do a lot of these
cases all over the globe.
It's always between 96% and 99%
of the women that hire us are right.
Guys are about 50%.
They know about half the time
if it's really happening or not.
They just tend to be more
wary of other men around
or things like that.
So it's about 50% with guys,
about 96% to 99% with women.
One of the big giveaways
is being overprotective of the cellphones
and the pads and any
of their other devices.
We've got a great
digital-forensics department.
Somebody brings us a
computer or a telephone,
we can retrieve, you know,
deleted texts, deleted pictures,
all those kind of things.
Mrs. Mulwray, this type of investigation
can be hard on your pocketbook.
It takes time.
Money doesn't matter to me, Mr. Gittes.
Most investigations are expensive.
It's not a cheap thing to get into.
For infidelity cases, I've had cases go
where we were watching somebody 24/7
for three weeks.
And I got on the phone
with my client, and I said,
"Hey, he's not doing what
you think he's doing."
And she says, "Andy, please stay on this.
I know."
And so we did, and, honestly,
it wasn't two days later before he was at
one of the high-end
hotels in Beverly Hills
with two prostitutes.
And then three days later,
we end up at a townhouse up in Agoura
where he paid for it
and he's had a woman living there with him
for years that nobody knew anything about.
So sometimes it takes a long time.
I would rate the accuracy of this scene
a 10 out of 10.
Following people on foot,
you definitely want to do
a lot of the things he did.
Stay out of sight,
don't look ridiculous enough
to everybody else around you
that they're saying,
"Hey, there's a guy, like,
hiding behind the wall watching
you go around corners."
You don't want to do that.
You always have to look
just like you belong there,
because it's not just that person
you have to worry about seeing you.
You have everybody else
that if you're acting
weird and stalkerish,
they're gonna go tell somebody.
Last thing you want to do
if you're following somebody
is have the police pull you over
to ask you what you're doing.
That kind of ends the
surveillance right there.
Quite often when we end
up in a on-foot situation
where we're doing a surveillance,
it started off in a vehicle.
So you don't know
exactly what you're
going to be able to do,
and like I talked about in
some of the other situations,
you have to be able to flow
with it as things change.
Almost all my guys, when
they're doing surveillance,
they'll have a couple extra shirts or tops
or maybe a pair of shorts.
Anything that they can switch out fast
to make themselves look different
and not catch the eye over
and over and over again.
Because if they're walking in an area
where there's not a lot
of people for a long time,
a lot of people take walks
in parks, things like that.
So you have to kind of
be ready to be on foot.
It wasn't terrible.
You want your disguise
not to be so ridiculous
that it's noticed as ridiculous,
because then they're going
to pay attention to you.
His was a little over the top there.
I'd give him a 7. 8. We'll go 8.
[gun fires]
[tires squeal]
The biggest misconception
people have about private investigators
is that we're always in gunfights
and that we're out arresting people.
And that's not very often what happens.
I'm not going to say
it doesn't ever happen,
but not very often.
And we don't drive a lot of Ferraris.
I would give this clip a 2.
In that scene, it's much
better than watching
the subject of the
investigation being followed
by a red Ferrari half
a car length behind him
and not noticing it.
If you can't be out of sight, blend in.
You want to use cars
that fit in everywhere.
I mean, we use a lot of
Priuses in Los Angeles.
The other thing is,
anytime you're following somebody
and you end up in a situation
where you're in a lot of traffic,
odds are they're going
to take a lot of turns,
things like that.
Of course, use a very inconspicuous car
and also try to use several.
That way somebody can leapfrog these.
We can have a car on the opposite way.
And if they come
and we know that this
one's going to take a left,
"Hey, coming towards you."
Then you're already in the street over,
you pick up the car, you go off.
The next one turns in behind
and then tries to leapfrog ahead.
If we have to speed, we do it.
It was amazing,
'cause he was actually
keeping an OK distance,
but there was never, ever
any traffic in between them.
Woman parks, and he
stops right in the lane
and sits and watches her.
That's a sure way to be seen.
So, not a good tail.
If you think somebody is tailing you,
start making unnecessary turns
into places that are odd
and then make multiple turns.
Make them follow you into those turns.
I'll give him 5, 'cause
I like Jimmy Stewart.
Rust: I remember there
was no physical evidence
connecting Dora Lange to the
dude's place out in the woods,
meaning it probably
didn't happen out there.
Yeah, it still happens a lot.
We use a lot of big whiteboards
with a lot of drawings through in this,
and then a lot of those
get erased as we go.
And we have lots of mirrored rooms
that the same thing happens with dry erase
and we put pictures on so we can see them,
and as things develop and change,
most cases just don't need
that kind of investigation,
but we use it a lot.
Rest of the family, they
don't really talk to Aunt D.
There's a whole plethora
of things that we can do
that law enforcement can't do.
We can talk to people,
I don't have to read you your rights.
I can start questioning
you from the beginning
with the intent of
having you confess to me.
Obviously, the biggest thing is
I can go anywhere in the world and work,
and I don't have to let
anybody know I'm there.
And we don't need to take a
ton of time for approvals.
So, if you tell me
that you need to have
a certain thing done,
we can prioritize it because
you're paying us to do it,
whereas law enforcement
may never prioritize it.
So they may never get to it
just because they're overrun.
In that part he did
pretty good, I thought.
In this scene, you've got a father
who's looking for a lost daughter.
He's obviously very bereaved.
I think he's doing the right
thing by going through this.
I think this is a very common scene.
I think that a lot of people
do these types of things
when this happens, even
before they call us.
Social media, websites, places
where they have memberships,
things like that are always important
in those kind of investigations.
We employ them a lot.
Some of the times you will use photographs
and things and do reverse imaging.
Now, I'm not talking about
doing a Google reverse image.
We use a lot of the
same soft- and hardware
that the FBI uses, that a
lot of law enforcement uses,
and it's only available
to licensed investigators
or law enforcement.
So we have very good people
that go and dig this stuff out.
And a lot of times, if you
have a daughter that's missing
or a son that's missing,
if we can have their computers,
we can get a lot of information
about what their thought process was
before they ended up missing.
There is no such thing as
secure on the internet. Nowhere.
If it can't be gotten right now,
it'll be available some other time.
You just see what happened to Facebook,
where Mark Zuckerberg's phone numbers
and everything else ended
up hacked from his own site.
So, nothing is safe.
I don't care who you are.
I don't care what site it is.
If you're putting it out there,
you might as well expect
that it's going to be
accessible to anyone.
So, at some point,
if the right person wants to get in there
and dig long and hard enough
and invest whatever it is,
time or money, they're going to find it.
I would give this a 10 out of 10.
It's a very accurate depiction
of what would happen.